[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend Ihnen auf Autobahnbaustellen oder
bei der Heizungsinstallation in der
Pflege oder im Krankenhaus beim Personal
an den Flughäfen oder auf dem Amt
überall kommen die Klagen in jedem
sechsten Beruf herrschen in Deutschland
laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit Engpässe
Fachkräftemangel das ist zu einem
geflügelten Wort geworden
schulterzuckend wenn irgendwo absurde
Wartezeiten erklärt werden müssen und
anklagend auf jedem Kongress der
deutschen Arbeitgeber
heute hat der Bundestag eine Reform der
einwanderungsregeln beschlossen die ist
durchaus umstritten und es ist nicht
sicher wie viel sich dadurch tatsächlich
besser wird aber die neuen Regeln mit
dem sperrigen Namen Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz markieren eine Wende
und es lohnt sich dass wir uns damit
eingehend befassen Frank Buchwald
hallo Herr Menschen wie sie braucht
Deutschland dringend anakoyun 28 stammt
aus Kamerun seit einem Jahr arbeitet die
Krankenschwester im katholischen
Klinikum Bochum in Westafrika verdiente
sie wenig Geld und hatte kaum
Perspektiven eine Freundin aus Wuppertal
kapiert den entscheidenden Tipp und sie
hat zu mir gesagt ja es ist möglich hier
deine Ausbildung hier anerkennen zu
lassen ne dann habe ich gesagt warum
nicht versuchen trotz Ausbildung aber
musste Schwester Anna noch mal eine
Prüfung überstehen und viele viele
Formulare ausfüllen das soll nun anders
werden der Bundestag hat ein neues
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
beschlossen künftig braucht man kein
kompliziertes Verfahren mehr um vorher
die Anerkennung dass in einem Land
anerkannten Berufsabschluss ist in
Deutschland nachzuholen das kann man
jetzt direkt mit einem Arbeitsvertrag
hier machen und das zweite wesentliche
Änderung ist die Chance hat die
chancenkarte ein Punktesystem wie in
Kanada wer Qualifikation
Sprachkenntnisse und Berufserfahrung
nachweisen kann nicht zu altes und einen
Bezug zu Deutschland hat hat künftig ein
Jahr Zeit für die Jobsuche wenn der
Lebensunterhalt gesichert ist das war
der FDP besonders wichtig die Opposition
nicht überzeugt
mit ihrem speziellen Punktesystem gerade
an die an die FDP gerichtet schaffen sie
ein
ampelbürokratiemonster von dem vor allen
Dingen Ausländer ohne Jobangebot und
ausreichende Qualifikation profitieren
was haben Sie eigentlich gegen die
Interessen der Wirtschaft was haben Sie
eigentlich dagegen eines der
erfolgreichsten Instrumente bei der
Einwanderung in den Arbeitsmarkt
auszudehnen das machen wir der AFD
Opposition passt die ganze Richtung
nicht
wir haben das Problem dass er viel zu
viele Menschen in unserem Land haben die
sich nicht sozialisieren die sich nicht
qualifizieren und die sich auch nicht
integrieren außer in unserer
Sozialsystem genau dies aber soll das
Gesetz verhindern nur wenn der
Lebensunterhalt gesichert ist sollen
Fachkräfte neben Ehepartnern und Kindern
künftig auch Eltern oder Schwiegereltern
mitbringen können das war den Grünen
wichtig neu der sogenannte Spurwechsel
qualifizierte Asylsuchende die vor dem
Stichtag Ende März dieses Jahres in
einem Job waren können auch als
Fachkräfte auf Arbeit zurückgehen
wir geben Menschen
ja zum warten und nichts tun verdammt
waren endlich eine Perspektive
langfristig in Deutschland beschäftigt
zu werden für uns zählt nicht woher
jemand kommt wenn man für uns zählt
alleine wohin er oder sie mit uns will
das sieht Anna kujun wohl ganz genauso
unterschiedliche Kultur die
Krankenschwester aus Kamerun angekommen
im Ruhrgebiet wo Einwanderer seit 100
Jahren zum Alltag gehören aus Polen
Italien der Türkei und aus aller Welt
die die Arbeit suchen und die die
händeringend Menschen suchen die
arbeiten beide zusammenbringen das ist
die Aufgabe der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
Professor Herbert Brücker leitet den
Bereich Migration Integration und
internationale arbeitsmarktforschung
beim Forschungsinstitut dieser
Bundesagentur für Arbeit ist also genau
der Experte mit dem wir jetzt über das
große Bild reden können und das tun wir
jetzt Herr Professor guten Abend ja
schönen guten Abend
Engpässe in jedem sechsten Beruf in
Deutschland ich habe vorhin schon kurz
gesagt das ist ja dramatisch wird sich
das jetzt mit dem neuen Gesetz alles
ändern
sind dramatisch nicht um jedem Wechsel
Beruf der flächendeckend das Gesetz
enthält viele sinnvolle Innovationen
also zwei sind besonders zu nennen das
eine ist wir können jetzt wenn die
Menschen der Gehaltsschwelle
überschreiten können wir auf die
gleichwertigkeitsprüfung verzichten das
mit die größte Hürde allerdings für die
gehaltsschwellen so hoch dass weniger
25% der Berufsanfänger aus dem Ausland
diese Schwelle überschreiten das heißt
es kommt diese Regelung wahrscheinlich
noch relativ wenigen Menschen zugute das
andere ist die chancenkarte die wir
dahinter stehende Idee ist dass man zur
Arbeit zu bekommen kann das ist per se
noch nicht attraktiv sondern die
Menschen wollen ja arbeiten ich arbeit
suchen dafür gibt es eine
Anschlussregelung und das
zusammengenommen hilft etwas aber es
bringt uns nicht die vielen 100.000
Arbeitskräfte die wir brauchen gehen wir
noch mal im Detail durch ja Professor es
gab heute im Bundestag von der
Opposition heftige Kritik daran die sagt
das Gesetz bringen vor allem die
Zuwanderung von
gering Qualifizierten aus aller Welt und
ein neues Bleiberecht für die die
eigentlich ausreisen müssten wen wird
denn diese neue einwanderungsregelung
anziehen aus ihrer Sicht
also gucken wir das den Gesetzestext an
also dort ist immer die Rede von
qualifizierten Arbeitskräften also
Menschen mit beruflichen Abschlüssen und
Hochschulabschlüssen die einzige Frage
um die es geht ist ob die ihre
Abschlüsse hier in Deutschland noch
deutschem Recht anerkannt werden müssen
oder ob man da drauf verzichtet sie
müssen nur im Heimatland anerkannt sein
und dann hat man bestimmte gehaltswellen
also es geht um qualifizierte und
hochqualifizierte Arbeitskräfte an die
sich das Gesetz richtet es gibt eine
Ausnahme die wir balkanregelung aber die
hat sich in der Vergangenheit als sehr
erfolgreich herausgestellt und betrifft
eben auch nur eine kleine Ländergruppe
aber warten denn die hochqualifizierten
in aller Welt jetzt nur darauf bei uns
also ich sag nur mit hohen Steuern mit
hohen Abgaben mit viel Bürokratie
wenig Betreuungsplätzen für Kinder und
nicht besonders hohen Löhnen arbeiten zu
dürfen
mein Debatten nicht wir stehen im
internationalen Wettbewerb
und Deutschland ist in generell ein
attraktives Land wir bezahlen hohe Löhne
aber wir sehen eben auch das relativ
wenig Menschen tun es kommen über die
erwerbskanäle die sind immer noch viel
zu kompliziert und wir werden auch nach
der Verabschiedung dieses Gesetzes
weiter sehr kompliziert bleiben und
dadurch fallen wir in den Wettbewerb
hinter die USA hinter Kanada und
ähnliche Länder zurück die würde es
Innenministerin hat gesagt das ist das
modernste es sei das modernste
Einwanderungsrecht der Welt wenn ich sie
so höre ist es auch das komplizierteste
warum warum eigentlich warum warum
machen wir das in Deutschland immer so
kompliziert
ich glaube das Grundproblem ist dass wir
die Vorstellung haben dass die Menschen
die zu uns kommen genauso sein müssten
wie wir und das sind sie natürlich nicht
wir bringen andere Qualifikationen mit
zum Teil höhere Qualifikationen sind
aber im Wesentlichen anders und nicht
nach der deutschen DIN-Norm und davon
müssen wir uns eben verabschieden wir
müssen anerkennen dass diese Menschen
wichtige Qualifikation mitbringen das
muss im Arbeitsmarkt getestet werden
aber nicht durch die Bürokratie sollte
eigentlich zu verstehen sein noch ein
anderes Thema was sie besprechen müssen
die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die verwaltet
derzeit rund 2,5 Millionen Arbeitslose
hier bei uns weshalb lassen sich in
dieser Lage in der ja sehr viele
Branchen händeringend suchen Millionen
offenbar nicht vermitteln
ja es ist schwierig weil die Menschen
häufig nicht genau zu den Jobs passen es
gibt Menschen die zum Teil sehr lange
schon arbeitslos sind die nicht jede
Tätigkeit machen können beispielsweise
in der Gastronomie wo man relativ jung
sein muss beweglich im Kopf das geht
nicht über Nacht aber die
Arbeitslosigkeit wenn wir davon absehen
dass jetzt ja sehr viele geflüchtete
Menschen nach Deutschland gekommen ist
sinkt tendenziell und wir werden
wahrscheinlich in Kürze mehr offene
Stellen haben als Arbeitslose in
Deutschland das heißt im Grundsatz haben
wir ein flächendeckende
Arbeitskräftemangel und auch den
Arbeitslosen hilft im Prinzip wenn die
Wirtschaft wächst und das geht nur wenn
wir neue Arbeitskräfte haben und da habe
ich noch eine ganz ganz große Frage wenn
man so will an Sie als Arbeitsmarkt
Forscher eine Umfrage oder viele
Umfragen aktuell ergeben wieder dass die
Mehrheit der Deutschen offenbar glaubt
Zuwanderung habe eher Nachteile ist denn
die Stimmung in diesem Land also ich
meine jetzt das gesellschaftliche Klima
überhaupt bereit für so eine
einwanderungs für so einen
Einwanderungsgesetz
ja ich habe da manchmal auch Zweifel das
geht da glaube ich auch sehr viel
durcheinander fluchtmigration andere
Migration die wir haben aber wir müssen
erkennen wir brauchen 400.000
Arbeitskräfte im Saldo pro Jahr oder
400.000 Menschen im Saldo pro Jahr um
das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial das
Arbeitsangebot konstant zu halten und
wenn uns das nicht gelingt kommt die
Sozialsystem in eine Schieflage und wir
profitieren am Ende alle von Migration
ich glaube dass diese Botschaft auch
noch ankommen wird das ist die Botschaft
heute Abend von Professor Herbert
Brücker Arbeitsmarkt Forscher Professor
herzlichen Dank für die sonderlöse sehr
lecker danke schön ja das Thema
Arbeitsmarkt und Einwanderung schlägt
hohe Wellen in diesem Land wir haben
schon drüber gesprochen gerade die AFD
hat heute in der Bundestagsdebatte
gesagt Deutschland sei kein
Einwanderungsland sondern ein Heimatland
das sind Sätze die offenbar Ankommen in
Thüringen wo kommen das Jahr gewählt
wird liegt die AFD in den Umfragen vor
allen anderen auch vor der Linkspartei
die immerhin aktuell den
Ministerpräsidenten stellt aber in
Thüringen gleich gegen eine ganze Reihe
von Problemen kämpft manche hausgemacht
manche grundsätzlich Melanie Haag
rustikales Ambiente Bratwurst und Musik
Martin Schirdewahn hat den Altenburg
Vereine und Genossen eingeladen
Thüringen eigentlich ein Heimspiel wo
der einzige linke Ministerpräsident
regiert und doch läuft es auch hier
nicht mehr so richtig rund klassische
Themen allein ziemlich mehr
ja wir müssen natürlich jetzt
vorausbringen und auch gucken welche
gesellschaftlichen Themen tatsächlich
von Relevanz sind die wir aufgreifen
müssen die wir auch mit klarer
einheitlicher Stimme und daran hat es
hin und wieder in der Vergangenheit
gemangelt doch die Linke im Bund steckt
im Umfrage tief die Wagenknecht
Diskussion der Richtungsstreit und
verliert schon lange Mitglieder die
Linke und ihre Vorgänger von 1990 bis
220.000 weniger den Fuß spürt man auch
hier auf dem Fest
Berlin gegangen die haben sich da die
Köpfe eingerannt schade weil wie gesagt
weniger Parteien kümmern sich überhaupt
um soziale Fragen und das war immer die
Linke wenn man diese querellen im
Prinzip
beseitigen könnte bzw aufheben könnte
indem man eine Linie fährt die alle
unter einem Dach halten kann wo die
Ziele tatsächlich auch zusammengeführt
werden das vermisse ich irgendwo die
Zerrissenheit der Linken auch bei den
Wählern kommt das an die einzige
Kümmerer an Protestpartei regiert in
Thüringen pragmatisch hat
corona-maßnahmen mitgetragen und
Russland Sanktionen doch dagegen gehen
Sie hier in Altenburg jeden Montag auf
die Straße bis heute Protest eher von
rechts getragen die Linken scheinen
vielen aus der Zeit gefallen
die haben noch nicht ganz begriffen
was erforderlich ist hier und jetzt und
dann kannst du keine Partei mehr hier
wahrnehmen oder ernst nehmen
und wenn da wieder gewählt werden
rund ein Jahr vor der Landtagswahl hat
die AFD in Thüringen die Linke als
stärkste Kraft in den Umfragen überholt
wir stehen hier in Thüringen jetzt vor
einer Landtagswahl und auf die bereiten
wir uns auch gemeinsam vor und aus
dieser Perspektive müssen wir auch
deutlich machen dass die AFD ein
gewichtiger Faktor in Ostdeutschland
geworden ist der die Gefühle abholt die
was mit Ausgrenzung und Verletzung zu
tun haben ausgerechnet im Osten wo einst
die Linke ihre großen Erfolge feierte
und nun neue Rezepte sucht
Freitagabend im ZDF heute journal jetzt
sein erster Nachrichtenüberblick mit
Johanna
beim Medikamenten beschlossen so werden
die Hersteller verpflichtet für
bestimmte viel genutzte Arzneimittel
einen Vorrat anzulegen dieser soll
künftig für sechs Monate reichen zudem
ist geplant Preisregeln zu lockern um
Lieferungen nach Deutschland lukrativer
zu machen und für Apotheken soll es
leichter werden bei Engpässen auf
ähnliche verfügbare Präparate
auszuweichen mit der Abstimmung
beschlossen die Abgeordneten außerdem
dass die telefonische Krankschreibung
unbefristet möglich wird
im Tarifstreit mit der Deutschen Bahn
hat sich die EVG prinzipiell offen für
eine Schlichtung gezeigt sollte die
Deutsche Bahn mit einer
schlichtungsforderung an die EVG
herantreten könne die Gewerkschaft
schnell entscheiden sagte der
evg-vorsitzende Burkhard den Bayerischen
Rundfunk es sei jederzeit möglich wieder
an den Verhandlungstisch zu kommen die
VG hatte die Tarifverhandlungen am
Mittwoch für gescheitert erklärt und
gestern eine Uhr Abstimmung über
unbefristete Streiks angekündigt
zwei Tage lang wurde bei einem
internationalen Gipfel in Paris darüber
beraten wie der Klimaschutz finanziert
und ärmere Länder besser unterstützt
werden können auch wenn es um die Folgen
der Klimakrise geht zum Abschluss wurden
bessere Finanzhilfen in Aussicht
gestellt der französische Präsident
macron betonte es herrschte Einigkeit
darüber dass das weltweite Finanzsystem
effizienter und gerechter werden müsse
bindende Entscheidungen wurden bei dem
Gipfel nicht getroffen
zum Abschluss des luftwaffenmanövers
eher Defender 2023 hat die Bundeswehr
eine positive Bilanz gezogen die Übung
sei reibungslos verlaufen sagte der
Inspekteur der Luftwaffe Gerhards es
habe zudem nur wenige Einschränkungen im
zivilen Flugverkehr gegeben an dem
zehntägigen Manöver unter deutscher
Führung waren rund 10.000 Soldaten und
250 Flugzeuge aus der NATO und weiteren
Ländern beteiligt er Defender war die
größte verlegeübung von
Luftstreitkräften seit Gründung der NATO
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossi ist nach
Kaliningrad gereist und hat dort mit dem
Chef der russischen Atombehörde über die
Situation des ukrainischen
Atomkraftwerks saporicia gesprochen auf
Twitter schrieb Rossi von einem
rechtzeitigen treffen ohne jedoch genaue
Details zu nennen der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hatte Russland erst
gestern vorgeworfen einen Terrorangriff
auf das Atomkraftwerk zu planen das AKW
wird von Moskau kontrolliert und war
immer wieder unter Beschuss geraten
das ist Krieg sagen die Ärzte in einem
Krankenhaus für Soldaten in Kiew zu
meiner Kollegin Alissa jung solche
Verletzungen gibt es im zivilen Leben
nicht
das ist nicht der einzige Satz aus der
Reportage gleich der im Gedächtnis
bleibt das ist Krieg Krieg ist
menschenverachtend Krieg ist immer auch
Niederlage wir zeigen Ihnen jetzt
Ärztinnen und Ärzte in der Ukraine die
selbst kämpfen müssen auf ihrem Gebiet
und wissen dass sie nicht jeden Kampf
gewinnen werden es gilt der hobbitsatz
mut bedeutet nicht ein Leben zu nehmen
sondern es zu bewahren
war es eine Kugel eine Mine oder ein
Schrapnell diese Informationen sind
wichtig Unfallchirurg Maxim per Roberts
muss jetzt schnell handeln es ist sein
Alltag hier in diesem Kiefer Krankenhaus
ist eine OP vorbei folgt direkt die
nächste die Entscheidung des Arztes
oftmals folgenschwer
jetzt kommt ein Patient wo ich in jedem
Fall dabei sein muss weil ich den Fuß
beurteilen muss ob es überhaupt eine
Chance gibt ihn zu retten oder ob wir
eine Amputation durchführen müssen
[Musik]
das ist Krieg solche Verletzungen gibt
es im zivilen Leben nicht sagen die
Ärzte doch auch darin sind sie
inzwischen routiniert geworden
sie haben gesehen ich habe den Fuß
berührt ein Teil ist warm ein Teil des
Fußes ist leider kalt wird dieser
Patient jemals wieder auf seinen eigenen
Beinen laufen können Maxima Roberts will
alles versuchen schwer verwundet an der
Front mit der Offensive im Süden ist die
Arbeit der Ärzte noch herausfordernder
geworden Krankenhäuser in Front Nähe
können nicht immer die nötige Versorgung
leisten
die aktuell kommen haben schwere
Verletzungen mit vielen Wunden wir sehen
manchmal dass die Krankenhäuser
überlastet sein müssen
bei der Montage nehmen der Patient wird
nochmal operiert werden müssen unklar ob
er sein Bein behalten wird wo sich
dieses Krankenhaus genau befindet dürfen
wir aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht sagen
in jedem Gang in jedem Zimmer ein Soldat
mit seiner eigenen Geschichte von der
Front von Vadim für Vadim dieses Bild
hat ein Kind aus dem Dorf gemalt für den
22-Jährigen Soldaten seit vier Monaten
ist er in diesem Krankenhaus verletzt in
bachmut im Kampf
dann haben sie das Artillerie vorher
gestartet und eine Mine ist explodiert
wir waren zu fünft die Mine landete
direkt in unserer Mitte zwei Jungs sind
gestorben und ich habe irgendwie
überlebt
aber beide Beine verloren und seinen
Kameraden
sie mussten entscheiden wen sie retten
mich oder einen anderen Jungen und am
Ende wurde ich gerettet und der andere
ist gestorben
wie groß ist der Schmerz ich kann es
aushalten sagt Vadim seit dem Angriff
war er nicht mehr zu Hause und wird wohl
noch länger hier bleiben müssen er weiß
so kann er kein Soldat mehr sein bei dem
hofft auf Prothesen will wieder laufen
lernen ob das geht und wann das weiß er
nicht
die russischen Angriffe auf die Ukraine
sind auch in der vergangenen Nacht
weitergegangen der Krieg ist nicht
vorbei und selbst wenn er das irgendwann
ist seine Wunden werden
so Hannah du machst noch mal Nachrichten
jahrelang wurden Immobilien in
Deutschland teurer und teurer doch
mittlerweile wird die Wände immer
deutlicher die Immobilienpreise sind
Anfang des Jahres so stark gesunken wie
seit 23 Jahren nicht mehr Valerie Haller
womit lässt sich das begründen liegt das
nur an den gestiegenden Zinsen nein
dafür gibt es eine ganze Reihe von
Gründen einer könnte sein dass die
aktuellen Krisen Menschen schlichtweg
verunsichern und sie davor zurückscheuen
die vermutlich größte Investitionen
ihres Lebens zu tätigen ja und dann
kommen natürlich tatsächlich noch die
kräftig gestiegenen Bauzinsen hinzu
dadurch sind Kredite deutlich teurer
geworden ja und dann noch die hohe
Inflation viele Menschen können sich den
Immobilienkauf einfach nicht mehr
leisten im ersten Quartal sanken die
Preise um durchschnittlich 6,8 % im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr der stärkste
Rückgang seit 23 Jahren in den Städten
verbilligten sich ein und zwei
Familienhäuser sogar noch stärker um
10,4%
diese Entwicklung die zieht aber auch
Kreise des Neugeschäft der Banken
beispielsweise mit Krediten liegt seit
Monaten am Boden und die Bauwirtschaft
klagt über Auftragsflaute was bedeutet
das denn jetzt für die Krise am
Wohnungsmarkt und das Problem ist dass
auch die Baukosten stark gestiegen sind
darum rechnen die Wirtschaftsforscher
des ifo-Instituts damit das künftig
deutlich weniger gebaut wird schon jetzt
fehlen laut Mieterbund rund 700.000
Wohnungen die Krise am Immobilienmarkt
dürfte sich in den kommenden Jahren also
weiter verschärfen der Druck auf die
Mieten weiter hoch bleiben vielen Dank
Valerie für deine Einordnungen
das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat dem
Verkauf der wärmepumpensparte von
Viessmann an einen US-Konzern zu
bestimmen allerdings nur unter der
Bedingung dass die im Vertrag
enthaltenen Klauseln zur
Standortsicherung eingehalten werden
demnach sind betriebsbedingte
Kündigungen für drei Jahre
ausgeschlossen die wichtigsten Standorte
müssen mindestens fünf Jahre erhalten
bleiben und der Hauptsitz des
Unternehmens muss für zehn Jahre das
hessische Allendorf bleiben
nach den schweren Unwettern gestern hat
sich die Lage wieder beruhigt die
Schäden blieben laut Versicherern im
Rahmen aber einige Nachwirkungen waren
den Tag über noch sichtbar manche
Zugstrecken betroffen Verbindungen
vielen aus wie hier in Kassel einige
Flüge verspäteten sich oder mussten
gestrichen werden die Feuerwehr hatte
mancherorts auch heute noch gut zu tun
ein unterspülter Deich an der Emscher
bei Dinslaken musste gesichert werden
mittags war die Lage wieder im Griff
zum Sport Tennisprofi Alexander Zverev
hat beim ATP-Turnier in Halle Westfalen
nun schon zum dritten Mal das Halbfinale
erreicht der 26-Jährige wird Zwang heute
Nikolas Yari aus Chile mit sieben zu
fünf und sechs zu drei im Kampf um den
Einzug ins Finale trifft morgen auf
Alexander bublik aus Kasachstan
nach den rassistischen Beleidigungen
gegen die Deutschen U21 Nationalspieler
kam hat der Deutsche Fußballbund
angekündigt juristisch gegen die Täter
vorzugehen die beiden Stürmer hatten im
em-auftaktspiel gegen Israel beide einen
Elfmeter verschossen und damit die
Chance auf einen Sieg vergeben
verärgerte Fans hinterließen darauf hin
rassistische Kommentare in den sozialen
Netzwerken Bundestrainer die salvo
bezeichnete die Beleidigungen als und
Ding
wir berichten hier ja viel und oft über
die Probleme vor denen dieses Land steht
über Zerwürfnisse und Herausforderungen
Deutschland kann aber auch anders
Deutschland kann überraschen zu Lande
und zu Wasser 1.600 Kilometer in acht
Wochen vom höchsten Punkt bis zum
nördlichsten Deutschland als
Abenteuerland das zeigt ein neuer Film
der jetzt im Kino läuft Abenteuerland so
heißt der auch zusammengefasst in den
kommenden drei Minuten jetzt bei uns von
homera rein
das fühlt sich so gut an das fühlt sich
so gut an jetzt hier oben zu stehen
jetzt geht's nur noch bergab mit dem
Stand Up Paddle ist wohl noch niemand
die Zugspitze hinab gestiegen Christoph
Förster startet in knapp 3000 Metern
Höhe sein verrücktes das Abenteuer sein
Plan von hier bis zum nördlichsten Punkt
des landesreisen in nur acht Wochen bis
nach Sylt
ich bin vor allem gleich am ersten Tag
sehr an meine Grenzen gekommen weil ich
ja die Zugspitze runter gestiegen bin
mit meinem ganzen Gepäck und ich habe
mein Stand-Up paddle Board auf der
Zugspitze dabei gehabt insgesamt über 40
Kilo denn sein Ziel will der Abenteurer
nur zu Fuß und auf seinem Support
erreichen gute 1600 km auf einsamen
Wegen und fließen
erstmal war das eine erstaunliche
Erkenntnis dass ich wirklich so alleine
bin da draußen ich war ja in Deutschland
und trotzdem bist du auf diesen Flüssen
so allein da ist kaum jemand unterwegs
ist eine ganz schöne fantastische
Perspektive der Film zieht einen von der
ersten Minute an in seinen Bann man hat
das Gefühl dabei zu sein kann die
Erschöpfung nachempfinden wenn Christoph
Förster ganze Tage zu Fuß zurücklegen
muss komplett durchnässt weil es einfach
nicht aufhören will zu regnen
das ist es fast wie so ein
strukturierter Arbeitstag morgens immer
das gleiche ich stehe auf ja dann packe
ich meinen Kram zusammen als als erstes
und dann schneide ich die Sachen auf
Sport und dann fahre ich los mehr mache
ich nicht
unterwegs sein auf seiner Expedition
wird der Hamburger immer wieder von dem
Filmemacher Kai hattermann begleitet
eine Freundschaft die seit 25 Jahren
besteht und während des Drehs manchmal
auf die Probe gestellt wurde der eine
möchte die Reise hinter sich bringen der
muss Kilometer machen dass er auch in
der richtigen Zeit ankommt und die
andere Seite wollte eben schöne Bilder
schießen ne und dann stehst du irgendwo
und siehst irgendein Part von dem Fluss
und denkst war da müssen wir filmen und
dann siehst Du oder ist ja schon vorbei
schafft sich über die unruhige Ostsee zu
kämpfen hat Christoph Förster auch
seiner körperlichen Fitness zu verdanken
seit vielen Jahren schon ist er als
Extremsportler in der Natur unterwegs
ich würde überhaupt in die Reise kann
jeder durchstehen es kommt ein bisschen
drauf an wie lange es dann dauert wie
viel Zeit man hat für mich war das
irgendwann eher ein wirklich erleben
genießen im Moment und gar nicht so sehr
dieses immer aufs Ziel hingucken das hat
mich zwar jeden morgen weitermachen
lassen aber das Ziel war am Ende gar
nicht so wichtig der Film ist eine
Liebeserklärung an Deutschlands schöne
Landschaften er macht Lust Neues zu
entdecken und sich selbst auf den Weg zu
machen
[Musik]
ja also wir sind morgen wieder für Sie
da vielleicht
und später gibt es unser heute journal
Update gegen 0:10 Uhr mit Gundula Gause
das ist ganz sicher danke für Ihr
Interesse angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
ja ein wunderschönen guten Abend zum
Wetter und zu Beginn blicken wir noch
einmal zurück auf den gestrigen
unwettertag da sind nämlich teils enorme
Regenmengen zusammengekommen vor allem
in Nordrhein-Westfalen Bad Sassendorf am
Südrand der Westfälischen Bucht
verzeichnete 102 Liter pro Quadratmeter
so viel ist an dieser Station in einem
Tag noch nie vom Himmel bekommen aber
auch in Richtung Osten Felgen treu
südwestlich von Berlin 62 Liter pro
Quadratmeter gestern und vor allem in
den mittleren und in den östlichen
Regionen kamen ja heute noch mal etwas
dazu und zwar in diesen regengebieten
die sich um das tiefzentrum hier
eindrehen vielen heute noch mal bis zu
50 Liter pro Quadratmeter wegen jetzt in
der ersten Nachthälfte zieht das ganze
aber ostwärts ab und dann hat die
Wetterberuhigung von Westen her mit
diesem hochheben schon eingesetzt heute
Nacht also der letzte ungewitzige Regen
von Vorpommern bis nach Ostbayern der
lebhafte Nordwest und lässt auch spürbar
nach der hinterbildet sich etwas Nebel
die Temperaturen sinken auf 15 Grad an
den Küsten und 9 Grad in höheren Lagen
beispielsweise der Oberpfalz also eine
Nacht zum Durchlüften morgen wird es
dann von Westen Herbert schon wieder
heißer 29 bis 31 Grad sonst gibt es aber
angenehme Temperaturen zwischen 22 und
27 Grad im Land im Norden sind die
Wolken dazu etwas dichter es fällt aber
kaum etwas raus ansonsten gibt es viel
Sonne und ein paar harmlose Quellen oder
hohe Wolken am Himmel der Sonntag wird
ein richtiger Sommertag mit Temperaturen
bis 34 Grad im Nordosten gibt es ein
paar mehr Wolken am Montag wird es
unbeständiger mit einer Kaltfront von
West nach Ost gibt es Schauer und
Gewitter aber die fallen nicht mehr so
stark aus wie noch am gestrigen Tag das
war's von uns tschüss